Zwei Sprechstunden. Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Der Sendung, wo in regelmäßigen Abständen der Chaos Computer Club oder nähere Expertinnen und Experten aus dem Umfeld, der das Studio enttarnt, um Dinge zu erklären, die irgendwie mit diesem seltsamen Internet zu tun haben oder neuartigen Rotfunk- umfangsgeräten oder irgendwas anderes digitales. Und heute wird es politisch. Heute wollen wir mal angucken, wie das aussieht mit der nächsten Bundestagswahl. Die ist ja bald, also im Herbst. Und da gibt es ja viele Wahlversprechen und viele Themen. Und da wollen wir uns hier in einem Chaosradio natürlich eher den digitalen widmen. Aber es ist ja sehr einfach, immer auf Wahlversprechen zu gucken und dann zu überlegen, ja gefällt mir das oder nicht. Wir wollen heute auch das machen. Aber viel sinnvoll ist ja vielleicht mal zurückzugucken und zu gucken, was haben denn die, die da waren, an der Macht, in der Regierung oder vielleicht auch einfach im Parlament gesessen, in den letzten Jahren so getrieben, in den letzten vier Jahren. Das wollen wir heute mal hier genauer uns angucken und anhören. Und dazu grüße ich recht herzlich Katharina Nocun. Hallo, guten Abend. Christian Dschefal. Hallo.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück beim Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo wir heute über die Digitalpolitik der letzten vier Jahre sprechen. Zu Gast sind Katharina Nocun. Hallo und guten Abend. Dein offizieller Titel ist eigentlich Digital Aktivistin oder was sagt man?
Äh, gute Frage.
Herzlich willkommen Katharina Nocun. Variiert. Äh, Christian Djefal vom Humboldt Institut für Internet und Gesellschaft.
Genau.
Der am Wahlkompass digital so rum mitgearbeitet hat und Annabie Selje von netzpolitik.org, das dafür bekannt ist, ganz genau hinzugucken, was die Politiker digitalen zu tun haben. Hallo und guten Abend. So, wir haben gerade schon ein bisschen gesprochen über die erste Zeit, dass es sehr lange nichts passiert ist, dass dann sozusagen Gesetze erlassen wurden, die unter anderem mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu tun haben, die wir jetzt schon durchgearbeitet haben. Und ich möchte jetzt diese Gelegenheit, dass die Sendung halb vorbei ist, und ich festgestellt habe, wir haben eine sehr lange Liste, also es ist schon was passiert in den letzten vier Jahren, die wir aber unmöglich in einer weiteren Stunde schaffen können, nach euren politischen Höhepunkten. Ich meine, es ist nicht vielleicht was ihr toll fandet, aber was ihr sozusagen bemerkenswert fandet. Also die letzte Legislaturperiode, was ist da das eine Ding, außer dass Frau Merkel vor der Wahl gesagt hat, dass das in der Neuland ist, auf das ihr euch auf jeden Fall noch erinnern werdet. Katharina, vielleicht können wir mit dir anfangen.
Ja, es gab viele Hoch- und Tiefpunkte. Als ich die Liste hoch durchgegangen bin, waren es halt eher viele Tiefpunkte. Was ich aber nicht vergessen werde, war so eine E-Mail von Edward Snowden, die bei uns irgendwann eingetrudelt ist. Ich habe 2014 bei Campact eine Kampagne geleitet, Asyl für Edward Snowden in Deutschland. Und in dieser E-Mail hat er sich bedankt und hat nochmal bekräftigt, dass er gerne nach Deutschland kommen würde und hat den vielen, vielen Menschen, die ausdauernd, auch nachdem es von den Titelseiten verschwunden ist, nicht nachgegeben haben, nochmal gesagt, weiter so. Das war für mich auf jeden Fall ein total krasser Moment. Und ansonsten mein Tiefpunkt, meine On-Off-Beziehung war so die Vorratsdatenspeise. Weil es für mich ja auch so etwas ist, was mich zur Politik gebracht hat. Und es war auch wirklich rauf und runter wie die schlimmste On-Off-Beziehung, die man sich vorstellen kann. Also erst hurra, Maas äußert sich, er will es nicht machen. Dann kommt das Paris-Attentat, dann kommt Druck von der Parteispitze und dann kommt es doch. Und ja, das war halt so der Abschluss, den ich nie vergessen werde, war halt wirklich der Tag, als das Gesetz verabschiedet wurde. Es hat in Strömen geregnet, alle waren nass bis auf die Knochen. Trotzdem standen wir da vom Bundestag und haben protestiert. Und nur ein einziger Abgeordneter, und zwar Marco Bülow von der SPD, ist rausgekommen. Wir haben alle anderen eingeladen, also bis auf Opposition, klar, aber von den Regierungsvertretern. Und da dachte ich halt wirklich, Scheiße, verkackt. Also wenn man wirklich gegen ein Projekt wirklich jahrelang demonstriert und irgendwie alle möglichen Instanzen sind in Bewegung. Und ja, jetzt dieser Lichtblick durch ein Münsteraler Gericht ist da halt noch mal wieder so ein kleiner Höhepunkt. Und ja, ich bin auch sehr zuversichtlich, dass das Thema uns in der nächsten Legislaturperiode nicht loslassen wird. Also Augen auf bei der Wahlentscheidung, was die Parteien zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung sagen.
Haben wir ja gerade schon geklärt, aber noch mal zu Snowden zurück. Ist eigentlich, was Whistleblower angeht, irgendwas passiert?
Ja, also die Lage hat sich auf gar keinen Fall verbessert. Also es ist nach wie vor so, dass wenn jemand beispielsweise über die illegalen Aktivitäten beim Bundesnachrichtendienst auspacken würde, hätte er ganz schlechte Karten in Deutschland. Es ist nach wie vor so, dass Whistleblower in sehr vielen Bereichen extrem krasse Wege auch auf sich nehmen, um Recht zu bekommen. Also da gibt es ja mehrere prominente Fälle, die bis vor den Europäischen Gerichtshof gegangen sind, beispielsweise von einer Whistleblowerin, die Missstände in der Altenpflege enthüllt hat. So, die musste sich zehn Jahre lang durch alle Instanzen klagen. Und man will sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie viel Mut und auch wie viel Pflichtbewusstsein vielleicht auch so in einem Menschen stecken muss, dass er wirklich alles aufgeht. Also man kann sich vorstellen, da bricht alles für diesen jemand weg. Job, Freunde meistens, man wird öffentlich noch in den Schmutz getreten und man hat eine riesen Anwaltsrechnung. Und von daher nach wie vor nichts passiert, aber natürlich viele große Worte zum Wahlkampf.
Ich glaube, es sind doch zwischendurch so ein Gesetz, wo man dann vermutet, dass dann selbst die Journalisten, die mit geleakten Dokumenten arbeiten.
Jaja, Datenhehlerei.
Genau, Datenhehlerei, das war's. Was war da noch mal genau damit?
Ja, also es war Teil des Paketes zum sogenannten BND-Gesetz. Das ist ja 2016 durchgewunken worden, also im letzten Jahr. Und da war es so, dass dann sogar Journalisten mit ins Visier geraten sind. Und zwar, wenn sie dann beispielsweise vertrauliche Dokumente von Whistleblowern zugeschickt bekommen oder irgendwie weitergeben, dann können sie da eben auch belangt werden.
Anna, wenn ich richtig geguckt habe voran ist, wenn ich jetzt nach Höhepunkt frage, ist BND sowieso ein Thema, oder?
Ja, BND-Gesetz ist natürlich irgendwie der Knaller. Also vor allem, weil wir ja mittlerweile diese ganzen Jahre im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss hinter uns haben, wo eigentlich alle zwei Wochen in der Sitzung immer Donnerstags irgendein neuer Skandal oder zumindest so ein neuer Kopf-auf-Tisch-Platte-Moment kam, was der BND so getrieben hat. Und dann kommt plötzlich noch, bevor diese Untersuchung abgeschlossen ist, ein Gesetz, das eigentlich nix anderes macht, als den ganzen Mist, den der BND gebaut hat, den er damals illegal gemacht hat, oder so. Das ist unter kreativen Rechtsinterpretationen legalisiert. Also das ist schon ein bisschen so ein Schlag ins Gesicht, wo man sich denkt, warum macht man den ganzen Kram eigentlich?
Warum macht man den ganzen Kram? Also das ist tatsächlich was, was ich mich manchmal frage, was Leute sozusagen oder wie sich Leute dazu motivieren, das trotzdem noch weiterzumachen.
Na manches wird ja auch besser oder zumindest nicht schlimmer. Also die Störerhaftung wurde zum Beispiel abgeschafft, sogar zweimal, weil es beim ersten Mal nicht so richtig geklappt hat.
Was war da los?
Na beim ersten Mal waren da immer noch relativ große Lücken drin. Das heißt, eigentlich würden wir dann ja mit Störerhaftung abschaffen, sowas erreichen, wie Leute können ihr WLAN auflassen, ohne dann eben Angst zu haben, abgemahnt zu werden. Da hat man das beim ersten Mal probiert, da waren da Rechtsunsicherheiten drin. Da hat man es noch ein zweites Mal gemacht, vor kurzem erst. Das hat meiner Einschätzung nach einigermaßen funktioniert. Das heißt, ich hätte jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt Angst, abgemahnt zu werden, wenn ich meinen WLAN aufmache. Das Problem ist nur, dass jetzt Inhalteanbieter, die eben Urheberrechtsverletzungen feststellen, noch hingehen können und sagen können, so ey, davon kam irgendwie die Urheberrechtsverletzung, du darfst unsere Seite nicht mehr aufrufbar machen. Aber das heißt nicht mehr, dass sie ihren Grund und Boden quasi in Zahlungen, in Unterlassungserklärungen erbringen.
Ist das Problem jetzt endgültig vom Tisch und wie haben sich da die Parteien verhalten?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie sie sich verhalten haben. Es gab einfach massiven Druck, auch von Seiten der Zivilgesellschaft. Ich muss sagen, die digitale Gesellschaft hat da eine ganz gute Arbeit gemacht und immer wieder Stellungnahmen hingeschickt. Und eigentlich musste man irgendwann einsehen, es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund, diese Störerhaftung weiter aufrechtzuerhalten. Also es gab irgendwie kein vernünftiges Argument dafür, irgendwie Leuten zu sagen, wenn ihr euer WLAN aufmacht, dann kriegt ihr Abmahnungen ins Haus.
Sind die Content-Industrie das auch so?
Ich glaube nicht. Aber die Content-Industrie ist jetzt nicht so der wahnsinnige Sympathieträger. Also ich glaube, dieses Geschäftsmodell von Abmahnanwälten, dass sie ihr gesamtes Geld damit verdienen, indem sie irgendwelche Leute abmahnen, die sich mal von der falschen Seite was runterladen, ist, glaube ich, niemandem so richtig sympathisch. Das ist jetzt keine Industrie, die man fördern will.
Christian, wie ist es denn bei dir eigentlich? Was ist denn dein netzpolitischer Höhepunkt aus der letzten Legislaturperiode oder Tiefpunkt?
Genau, ich habe einen Tiefpunkt, einen Höhepunkt. Der Tiefpunkt ist genauso wie bei dir eigentlich die G10-Gesetzgebung und vor allem auch der Blick in andere Länder und die Erkenntnis, dass eigentlich Massenüberwachungstools legalisiert wurden überall. Meine Hoffnung bei der Sache ist, dass das einfach der Beginn des rechtsstaatlichen Auseinandersetzungen mit diesen Gesetzen ist, die dann mit breiter Koalition bekämpft werden. Ein bisschen Hoffnung gibt mir, dass in Deutschland es doch auch schon ziemlich viele Leute gibt, die sich dagegen ausgesprochen haben. Unter anderem der konservative ehemalige Präsident des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, Hans-Jürgen Papier, der da eigentlich ein ziemlich kritisches Gutachten auch dazu geschrieben hat. Aber dass das auf der ganzen Welt eigentlich eine ähnliche Bewegung gab, diese Tools sozusagen zu legalisieren, das hat mich einfach erschüttert, muss ich sagen. Und der Höhepunkt ist im gleichen Kontext für mich ganz klar die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung. Also das europäische Datenschutzgesetz, das natürlich kritisch und diskutiert wurde, aber auch willkommen geheißen wurde. Was auf jeden Fall ein Unterschied ist, ist, dass der Datenschutz jetzt ein viel, viel schärferes Schwert hat und man spürt es richtig sozusagen.
Tatsächlich?
Ja.
Ja, also der Markt für Datenschutzbeauftragte ist halt momentan so ein bisschen leer, weil ganz viele große Unternehmen grad merken so, huch, hier ist ja so ein Aufgabenkatalog, den muss ich demnächst mal erfüllen. Und wenn nicht, dann riskier ich auch dann was.
Aber das ist genau die Frage, weil du sagst grad schärferes Schwert. Ich hab ja den, ja, ich hab bis jetzt immer so, also Datenschützer können eigentlich, da gibt es nichts, was sie so richtig machen können, außer vielleicht mal so ein bisschen Bußgeld verhängen. Was ist denn das scharfe Schwert, was sie jetzt bekommen haben?
Bußgeld in Höhe von vier Prozent des Unternehmensumsatz, Jahresumsatzes oder maximal in Höhe von, also alternativ von 25 Millionen Euro. Und vor allem diese vier Prozent des Unternehmensumsatzes für einzelne Datenschutzverstöße ist was, was sozusagen Datenschutzprobleme sofort in, bei einem großen Unternehmen sofort in den Vorstand bringt. Also das müssen dann die obersten, obersten in so einem Unternehmen entscheiden. Und dementsprechend wird das auch viel, viel wichtiger. Auf der anderen Seite das Marktortprinzip, das heißt, wer in Europa mit Daten tätig ist, muss sich an die Datenschutzregeln hier halten. Das heißt, Datenschutzbeauftragte werden nicht nur in Europa gesucht, sondern auch im, überall in der Welt, im Silicon Valley. Und wir haben eben auch, wir merken das bei Gastwissenschaftlern, es gibt ein ganz, ganz großes Interesse. Und gleichzeitig, zum Beispiel in Brasilien, ist das europäische Datenschutzrecht jetzt auch zum Vorbild geworden. Also, das gibt mir eine verhaltene Hoffnung, dass das doch viel wichtiger wird, als es früher war.
Das Deprimierende ist halt sozusagen, das Positivste, was man rausziehen kann, ist eine verhaltene Hoffnung.
Ja, wobei eigentlich, also ich würde das jetzt nicht der großen Koalition anrechnen, weil die kann da gar nicht so viel für, beziehungsweise die hat einiges dafür getan, dass es ein bisschen schlimmer wird.
Sondern wem haben wir das dann zu verdanken?
Na, das haben wir im Endeffekt der EU als solche zu verdanken. Also da waren ja noch mehr Leute daran beteiligt, außer deutschen Vertretern. Und außerdem hat dann die Bundesregierung dadurch, dass sie ja Teile dessen nochmal in deutschem Recht regeln musste, mit einem neuen Datenschutzgesetz, sag ich mal, diverse Sachen eingebaut, die das Ganze nochmal abschwächen. Also zum Beispiel hat sie dann in diesem Gesetz nochmal untergebracht, dass die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte von sich aus das Parlament nicht über Missstände bei Nachrichtendiensten informieren soll. Auch wenn das eigentlich nicht so viel damit zu tun gehabt hätte, aber sie haben das zumindest noch mal genutzt, um da noch ein paar Sachen rein zu drücken. Deshalb ja, dieses europäische Ding ist schön, aber das, was die Bundesregierung daraus gemacht hat, finde ich eher nicht so schön.
Ja, oder was auch noch, sag ich mal, ehrlich gesagt verstörend ist in Anbetracht diverser Entwicklungen im Bereich Gesundheitswesen, ist auch, dass, sag ich mal, präventive Datenschutzkontrollen bei Berufsgeheimnisträgern beim Umsetzungsgesetz jetzt in Deutschland eingeschränkt wurden. Das heißt, Datenschutzbeauftragte dürfen nicht mehr unangemeldet, sag ich mal, beispielsweise Ärzte kontrollieren. Und das sind zum Teil sensibler Daten. Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich hab mal auf dem Sperrmüll in so Krankenakten eines Frauenarztes gehöhlt. Und wenn man sich überlegt, das sind Daten, die nicht nur, sag ich mal, die Patienten selbst betreffen, sondern im Zweifel bei Erbkrankheiten eben auch die Kinder und Kindeskinder. Und ja, das ist, sag ich mal, so ein Beispiel, ähnlich wie bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo im Wustfortsatz noch andere Sachen dran gehängt wurden, die jetzt, sag ich mal, nicht im Kernbereich was damit zu tun haben, wurde, sag ich mal, unter dem Hurra-Jubel, dass die EU-Datenschutz-Grundverordnung jetzt kommt, von der Bundesregierung klammheimlich so eine Verschlimmbesserung eingeführt. Und da muss man eben aufpassen.
Ich bin jetzt kurz verwirrt. Bei der Vorratsanspeicherung war es ja immer so, dass eines der Argumente war, Moment mal, da sind ja auch die ganzen Berufsgeheimnisträger mit betroffen. Also Anwälte, Ärzte, Journalisten, deren Daten werden da auch gespeichert. Und das geht ja nicht, weil die ja von Beruf Geheimnisträger sind. Jetzt wird aber gesagt, also eigentlich wäre es eine gute Idee, wenn man Unangemeldet zu Berufsgeheimnisträgern kommt und mal deren Datenhaltung durchguckt. Wie passt das zusammen?
Naja, also mal so ein ganz konkretes Beispiel. Ich habe ja auch mal beispielsweise ein Praktikum beim unabhängigen Landesdatenschutzzentrum in Schleswig-Holstein gemacht, wo auch der Tilo Weichert damals Landesdatenschutzbeauftragter war. Und diesen teilweise eben auch, wenn Beschwerden kamen, dass beispielsweise in Arztpraxen eben Datenschutzverstöße da sind, eben auch mal hingegangen, um zu kontrollieren, um zu gucken, was denn da ist.
Aber gucken die sich dann die Daten an? Also die von der wir gerade sagten...
Naja, also einzelne Sachen, wie beispielsweise, ob irgendwo eine Videokamera in einem Umkleideraum hängt. Das ist halt so, siehst du halt relativ offensichtlich. Du kannst halt, sag ich mal schon, die einzelnen Sachen anschauen. Und zumindest, also man muss sich ja auch mal überlegen, in dem Bereich, wo klar ist, also wenn, sag ich mal, das Memen des rechtsfreien Raumes ist ja immer so sehr beliebt. Und wenn ich halt weiß, dass ich in keinem Fall mit einer Kontrolle zu rechnen kann, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das, sag ich mal, so den Datenschutzstandard unbedingt erhöht. Ich finde das absolut notwendig, dass die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte beispielsweise bei…
Aber nochmal, wie finden diese Kontrollen statt? Das kann mir nicht vorkommen. Wie kontrolliere ich sozusagen eine Datenbank darauf oder sozusagen die Computer eines Artes darauf, ohne mir die Daten anzugucken, von der ich eben genau nicht will, dass jemand anguckt, den ich nicht angehe, zum Beispiel mich als Datenschutzbeauftragter?
Aber das ist ja eigentlich ganz primitiv. Du kannst dir ja erst mal angucken, gibt es überhaupt ein Passwort für den Computer? Das heißt, steht der Computer einfach da rum und kann da jeder ran? Oder sind die Patientenakten in einem Schrank, den man abschließen kann? Das heißt, so Datenschutz gehört ja nicht nur die Datenbank. Da sind ja auch physische Sachen. Also kommt danach, keine Ahnung, kommt danach Praxis Schluss einfach jeder ran? Oder gibt es da eine Vorkehrung?
Also es geht sozusagen nicht darum, sich die Daten anzugucken, sondern die Struktur, in der die Daten liegen?
Und dann eben die Absicherung der Daten vor allem.
Kann man hier bei diesem Gesetz irgendwie noch Parteilinien ziehen? Also wir reden jetzt schon fast eineinhalb Stunden und ich hab so eine andere... Bei anderen Themen gibt es relativ krasse sozusagen, oder naja nicht krasse, aber sozusagen zumindest erkennbare Linien, sagen wir so. Und hier ist es eigentlich eher so, man muss eigentlich ja immer mit allen arbeiten. Man kann, also wir kommen ja nachher nochmal genau auf den Wahlkompass, aber dass du sagen, zumindest in den letzten 4 Jahren gar nicht so eine klare Parteilinien gab. Oder täuscht das jetzt?
Na das gab ja auch nur eine übergroße Koalition. Also wenn man sich so ein bisschen klarmacht, dass eine Opposition aus Grünen und Linken nicht mal ein Viertel der Stimmung ausmacht und das dann eine SPD mit einer CDU zusammen regiert, dann hat man irgendwann keinen Unterschied mehr. Ich meine, das ist ja der typische GroKo-Effekt, der da reintritt.
Na also ja, aber es ist zum Beispiel so, also Ehe für alle. Ehe für alle hat die SPD ja immer gesagt, also im Prinzip sind wir dafür, aber wir können gar nicht. Und das hat bei den Digitalteam, habe ich nicht den Eindruck, dass sie sich sozusagen nicht mal im Anschein sozusagen unterscheiden.
Na ich glaube, die SPD ist bei vielen gezwungen, mit der CDU mitzuziehen.
Nein, aber das meinte ich ja gerade. Das hat sie bei der Ehe für alle ja auch gemacht, aber trotzdem immer noch mal zwischendurch gesagt, also eigentlich finden wir es schon eine gute Idee, aber halt jetzt Koalitionsvertrag.
Na es gab halt zwischendurch so ein paar Einzelne der SPD mit gewissen, die dann halt gesagt haben, finden wir kacke.
Ja, es gab tatsächlich, es gibt so einzelne Ortsverbände von der SPD. Ich glaube, Eimsbüttel war das in Hamburg, die so sehr nachhaltig sich gegen die Vorratsdatensprechung engagiert haben, oder eben einzelne Abgeordnete. Oder beispielsweise bei den Jusos gibt es eine ganz klare Ablehnung der Vorratsdatensprechung. Man muss aber auch sehen, dass einige, sage ich mal, Jusos auf den vorderen Plätzen, die dann auch ans Mikro gegangen sind und gesagt haben, Sigmar Gabriel so nicht, wir wollen das nicht. Und wir sind dagegen. Die wurden dann auch abgestraft. Die sind nicht auf den vorderen Plätzen gelandet bei den Listenaufstellungen für die Bundestagswahl. Und das ist natürlich so ein, finde ich ganz schlimmer, disziplinierender Effekt innerhalb großer Parteien, deren halt auch die zulasten der Vielfalt geht. Und mein Feedback auch von vielen Jusos, mit denen ich über das Thema gesprochen hab, war, dass es auch schwierig ist, bei einem so hohen Altersdurchschnitt wie bei der SPD, da wirklich viele Menschen für das Thema zu sensibilisieren und zu mobilisieren. Und das ist, denke ich mal, bei, also, beispielsweise die Grünen haben ja einen geringeren Altersdurchschnitt. Die FDP auch. Die Linke ist, glaube ich, ungefähr genauso alt wie die SPD. Ja, das kommt erschwerend hinzu.
Ja, aber ich teile deinen Eindruck, also ich glaube, bei diesen großen Themen oder die großen Buzzwords schreiben sich eigentlich alle ins Programm. Der Teufel steckt dann im Detail. Nicht alle sind für Datenschutz, Innovation, IT-Sicherheit, aber was das bedeutet, sozusagen auf konkrete Fragen, ich glaube, da liegen dann Unterschiede und wie gesagt, auch innerhalb von Parteien nicht.
Wir sind jetzt, also das, also ja, okay, sag ich jetzt einfach so. Wir sprechen gleich in der letzten Halbzeit von Hobby Zukunft. Ich möchte jetzt, bevor wir zu den Nachrichten kommen, noch zwei kleine Details klären. Das eine ist, wir haben gleich noch eine Hörerfrage. Robin hat angerufen. Und das andere ist, in der Vorbereitungsliste, die ihr mitgegeben habt, steht auch etwas drin, wo ich so denke, was macht das hier? Das erste Gesetz zur Änderung des Gesetzes über den deutschen Wetterdienst. Was hat das mit Digitalthemen zu tun? Oder hat euch das jemand reingeschmuggelt und ihr wisst es auch nicht?
Ich kenne es nicht im Detail, aber es geht auf jeden Fall darum, wie der deutsche Wetterdienst seine Daten zur Verfügung stellen darf. Das war irgendwie auf jeden Fall was gut. Ich glaube, er darf jetzt mehr als vorher oder zumindest wurde es nochmal geregelt.
Okay, das ist das Überthema Open Data.
Genau.
Also es gibt ja diese Forderung, die Regierung kriegt ja von uns Geld durch die Steuern. Da werden ganz viele Daten produziert. Und die wollen wir eigentlich alle immer sehen. Und das zu sagen, der deutsche Wetterdienst ist da eine dieser Sachen. Gibt es da eigentlich? Also ich bin ja hier auf der Suche immer nach Parteilinien. Gibt es da sozusagen, was diese Open Data Nummer angeht, Dinge, wo man sagen kann, okay, da gibt es so konservative und liberale Ansichten?
Ich glaube, dass grundsätzlich mittlerweile die meisten für Open Data sind, aber aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Die einen betonen eher sozusagen eine Wirtschaftsförderung und den anderen geht es vor allem um Transparenz, Partizipation und die Möglichkeit der Kontrolle.
Aber es bildet sich so ein gesellschaftlicher Konsens ab, der auch in der Politik sich widerspiegelt? Letztlich ist es uns ja egal, warum, Hauptsache sie machen es.
Ich denke schon. Es gibt jetzt eben das Open Data Gesetz, das das E-Government-Gesetz auch für die Bundesministerien geändert hat. Die müssen jetzt auch mit gewissen Ausnahmen, aber in der Regel eben ihre Daten veröffentlichen. Und Deutschland ist auch international im Rahmen der Open Government Initiative tätig geworden, ist in einen Dialog mit der Zivilgesellschaft eingetreten. Und der gerade sozusagen mit der Lobbyarbeit bei Gesetzesinitiativen, da wurde auch auf Netzpolitik berichtet, ist über Informationsfreiheit sozusagen, über den Umweg von ganz vielen Informationsfreiheitsanfragen auch erreicht worden, dass alle Lobbyeingaben für die ganze Legislaturperiode veröffentlicht werden, zu jedem Gesetz. Das dauert jetzt eine ganze Weile, aber das scheint mir doch auch ein großer Fortschritt zu sein, dass alles transparent gemacht wird jetzt.
Das finde ich eigentlich auch eine erfreuliche Entwicklung, dass ich dafür, ja, konzentriert abzeichnet. Wer hätte das gedacht? So, jetzt haben wir noch Robin, 25 Jahre, aus Frankfurt, der eine Frage hat, die sich immer wieder stellt, wenn man über den Umgang mit geleakten Materialen spricht. Hallo Robin.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Bitte stell deine Frage.
Es geht mir noch mal kurz um ein Thema, was vorhin kurz angesprochen wurde, um die Datenhehlerei. Da hatte ich jetzt einfach nur mal so die Frage, weil da ging es darum, dass im Gespräch war, die Daten, die Whistleblower zur Verfügung stellen, und Journalisten dafür hafbar zu machen, wenn sie eventuell irgendwas damit anstellen. Und jetzt wollte ich einfach mal fragen, wie das denn eigentlich sein kann zum Beispiel, dass man auf der einen Seite so was strafbar machen will, und auf der anderen Seite aber zum Beispiel die deutschen Steuerbehörden, CDs einkaufen von ausländischen Banken zum Beispiel, um Steuerhinterzieher zu überführen. Weil das ist ja auch nicht legal. Das sind ja auch eigentlich beschaffte Daten, mit denen man so ohne Weiteres eigentlich nicht arbeiten dürfen sollte. Oder ja, wenn man jetzt mit dieser Datenhehlerei so aufgreift.
Kann man annehmen?
Ich hör Gerichte da im Hintergrund.
Oder ist das sozusagen, ist das etwas, wo ich ja auch sag Ja, stimmt, das wüssten wir auch gerne.
Ja, also das war auf jeden Fall auch so ein What-the-fuck-Moment. Also das sieht man aber leider häufiger, dass mit zweierlei Maß gemessen wird. Aber, ja.
Wir müssen leider an dieser Stelle passen. Wir wissen's auch nicht.
Kein Problem.
Dann viel Spaß noch.
Danke, euch auch.
So, ja, das ist ja auch schön. Dinge, die nicht geklärt sind. Gut, wir werden uns gleich mal mit der Zukunft beschäftigen. Können vielleicht klären, welche Parteien, was uns in Zukunft versprechen. Vorher gibt es noch eine kleine Musik vom Sommer 2017 Semmler von Z-Tapes, nämlich Picking Up Trash von Euphoria.
Die Londoner Polizei prüft nach dem Hochhausbrand im Grenfell Tower ein Verfahren gegen die Behörden wegen fahrlässiger Tötung. In einem Schreiben der Polizei heißt es, es gebe hinreichende Verdachtsmomente, um ein solches Verfahren einzuleiten. Die Polizei will Beamte der Stadtverwaltung und der für den sozialen Wohnungsbau zuständigen Organisation befragen. Bei dem Brand Mitte Juni waren mindestens 80 Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Das Feuer hatte sich schnell ausgebreitet, weil die Fassadenverkleidung leicht entzündlich war. Das Gewitter über Berlin hat am Abend zu Verzögerungen im Flugbetrieb geführt. Das haben die Flughafenbetreiber auf Twitter mitgeteilt. Ankommende Flüge hatten in Schönefeld teilweise mehr als 45 Minuten Verspätung. Auch in Tegel gab es Verspätungen. Manche Passagiere kamen erst rund eine Stunde später an. Nach dem tödlichen Angriff auf jüdische Siedler im Westjordanland hat Israels Ministerpräsident Netanyahu die Todesstrafe für den Attentäter gefordert. Der Regierungschef sagte, die Zeit für die Todesstrafe sei in extremen Fällen gekommen. Ein 19-jähriger Palästinenser hatte am vergangenen Freitag drei Israelis in einer jüdischen Siedlung getötet. Das israelische Recht lässt die Todesstrafe zwar zu, seit der Gründung des Staates wurde sie aber nur einmal angewendet. In der Nähe von Frankfurt Oder hat das Helene Beach Festival begonnen. Der tagelange Regen in Brandenburg hatte die Anreise etlicher Besucher verzögert und den Aufbau erschwert, wie die Organisatoren mitteilten. Straßen und Wege mussten verdichtet und Wasser abgebumpt werden. Das Musikfestival dauert bis zum Sonntag. Rund 120 Künstler sollen auf sieben Bühnen auftreten. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Zehlendorf und Adlershof 16 Grad, Ludwigshalde 15 Grad, Cottbus, Neuropin und Lindenberg melden aktuell 18 Grad. Am Abend und in der Nacht kann es vor allem im Süden noch schauern und gewittern, sonst bleibt es trocken. Der Freitag bringt Wolken und ein paar Schauer. Im Laufe des Tages lässt sich auch mal die Sonne blicken. Das Ganze bei Höchstwerten von 23 Grad in Berlin und 24 Grad in Brandenburg. Vorsicht auf der A10, nördlicher Berliner Ringen, Richtung Dreieck-Bahnim. Zwischen Dreieck-Pankow und Dreieck-Bahnim sind Radfahrer unterwegs. Vorsicht auf der A13, Berlin Richtung Dresden. Zwischen Barothmarck und Starkow steht ein defekter Lkw auf der Standspur. A24, Berlin Richtung Hamburg, zwischen Dreieck-Wittschok, Dosse und Raststätte, Stolpe Nord, ist ein Schwertransport unterwegs, den nicht überholt werden kann. Vorsicht auf der A115, Zubringer Nutetal Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Saarmoot und Potsdam-Drewitz steht ein defektes Fahrzeug auf der Standspur. Und Vorsicht im Kreis Uckermark auf der L284, zwischen Flimsdorf und Felcho befindet sich ein Rehbock auf der Fahrbahn. Allen unterwegs und da, wo es geht, nur gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz im Live- oder Musikstream hören wollt, dann geht doch mal auf fritz.de slash Streambox.
Im Chaos Radio in Blue Moon gibt's jetzt die Nerd-News, geschrieben von Moe vom Chaos Computer Club und präsentiert von Merlin Schulz.
Flash ist tot. Das Browser Plug-in Flash wird bis 2020 schrittweise eingestellt. Das hat der Hersteller Adobe am Dienstag verkündet. Das Flash Plug-in macht in den letzten Jahren zumeist durch Negativschlagzeilen auf sich aufmerksam. Flash verbinden viele User vor allem mit kritischen Sicherheitslücken, hohem Energieverbrauch, langen Ladezeiten und Browser abstürzen. Firefox stirbt. Der Mozilla-Browser Firefox ist vom Aussterben bedroht. Sein Marktanteil auf dem Desktop ist auf rund 14 Prozent geschrumpft. Microsofts Internet Explorer liegt bei gut 9 Prozent. Von der schwächelnden Konkurrenz profitiert vor allem Google Chrome. Sein Anteil am Desktop-Markt beträgt mittlerweile 63 Prozent. Roomba spioniert. iRobot, der Hersteller der Staubsagerroboter Roomba, will Daten über die Wohnung der Nutzer verkaufen. In einem Interview mit der Nachrichtenagentur Reuters räumte iRobot-Chef Colin Engel ein, dass das große datenschutzrechtliche Fragen aufwerfe. Er versicherte aber, dass man sich die Einwilligung der Nutzer einholen werde. Die würden dem aber sowieso zustimmen, um ihr Smart-Home smarter zu machen.
Falls ihr die Hürden-News selber noch mal nachlesen und nachklicken wollt, auf chaosradio.ccc.de gibt es nach der Sendung die passenden Links. Präsentiert wurden sie von Merlin Schulz. Vielen Dank. Chaosradio im Blumen, eine halbe Stunde haben. Entschuldigung, mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich habe einen Froschumhals. Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch, um uns über die Wahlprogramme der Bundestagsparteien und deren digitale Ausprägung zu unterhalten. Warum machen wir das? Weil wir heute in der Sendung einen Rückblick gehalten haben auf die letzten vier Jahre digitale Politik, die Regierung und auch der Opposition. Und wir haben eine Sache vergessen, nämlich den Staatstrojaner. Haben wir einen Staatstrojaner? Wer hat uns einen Staatstrojaner gebracht und was kann er überhaupt?
Wir haben eigentlich schon ziemlich lange einen Staatstrojaner. Also eigentlich darf man so einen Staatstrojaner seit 2009 einsetzen, aber nur für, also nur gegen Terror.
Na, aber der war doch auch kaputt zwischendurch, oder?
Der war kaputt, der durfte mehr als er sollte, als er, nee, der konnte mehr als er durfte, so rum. Und eigentlich ist das auch immer noch so, zumindest den, den man sich eingekauft hat, den prüft man jetzt, glaube ich, in der dritten Version. Und irgendwie kann er immer noch mehr als er darf. Das heißt, eigentlich darf man ja nur so laufende Kommunikation damit abfangen. Das heißt, bevor sie verschlüsselt wird, aber halt schon so laufende Kommunikation. Aber leider können die Dinge halt immer auch noch so gucken, was man so auf seinem Telefon hat und alte Nachrichten lesen. Und das kriegt man denen einfach nicht ausgetrieben. Also prüft man, prüft man, prüft man. Dann hat irgendwann das BKA gesagt, machen wir halt selber einen. Und da soll jetzt auf jeden Fall dieses Jahr noch eine erweiterte Variante kommen, die eben nicht nur Skype mitschneiden kann, sondern auch Sachen von Messagerdiensten lesen kann. Und es wurde ausgeweitet, wie man den einsetzen darf. Den darf man jetzt auch bei so Spaßeinsätzen wie Schmuggel von Anabolika. Also nicht mehr nur bösem Terror, sondern auch alles Mögliche andere.
Warte mal, war es nicht auch bei der Vorarztatenspeicherung so, dass die Kritiker gesagt haben, dass werden sie bestimmt noch für andere Sachen benutzt, als die ganzen Schwerverbrechen, die es am Anfang eingeführt wurde. Und dann kam das auch so?
Sowas würde bei Sicherheitsgesetzen niemals passieren.
Niemals. Das würde auch beispielsweise bei der PKW-Maut nie gemacht werden, was beispielsweise in einem neuen Unionswahlprogramm dann plötzlich gesagt wird, hoch, wir können es auch für andere Dinge verwenden, würden die niemals tun.
Aber es gibt doch gar keine PKW-Maut, die würde doch auch niemals kommen.
Wir leben in einem Paralleluniversum, in dem wir aber bald wieder wählen müssen. Aber ich will vorhin noch fragen, Staatsverwanderer, gibt es denn da so Parteilinien? So gibt es da dafür und dagegen Leute?
Ich glaube, die SPD hat sich schon eine Weile, wer oder weniger, gesträubt und da gab es dann auch zwei SPD-Lamitgewissen, die viel zitierten, die dann gesagt haben, ne, das können wir so nicht durchgehen lassen.
Warte mal, wir haben den ganzen Abend jetzt darüber gesprochen, es gibt zwei SPD-Lamitgewissen. Nur mal für den größten Vergleich, weil ich es leider gerade nicht im Kopf habe, wie viel Sitze hat die SPD?
Wie auch das will, das müssen wir in diesem Internet nachgucken.
Okay, gut, mach das mal jemand anders.
Aber ich muss sagen, in der Zwischenzeit, diese Ausweitung des Einsatzes Staatsroyal, das war schon ziemlich stunt, weil es ist eine kreative Hochleistung, wie sie das geschafft haben. Sie haben das nämlich untergebracht in einem Gesetz über das Fahrverbot als Nebenstrafe. Was? Ja, über das Gesetz als Fahrverbot als Nebenstrafe, damit man zum Beispiel Jugendliche abschrecken kann, irgendwelche bösen Dinge zu tun, indem man sagt, dann nehmen wir deinen Führerschein weg. Sachen, die gar nichts mit dem Fahren zu tun haben. Und dann war dieses Gesetz irgendwie schon so ein bisschen fertig und dann hat der Bundestag noch mal eine Formulierungshilfe von der Bundesregierung bekommen, was sie denn da noch so reinmachen könnte. Und das war dann plötzlich der Staatstrojaner. Unglaublich witzig, weil selbst die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte wusste das nicht, die hat das dann bei uns gelesen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein ziemlich geiler Stunt, wenn man irgendwas unterbringen will, auf jeden Fall in einem Gesetz unterbringen, das überhaupt nicht so klingt, als könnte man es da unterbringen, zum Beispiel das Fahrverbot als Nebenstrafe.
Das ist ja ganz großartig. Und da hat die SPD zugestimmt. Ach ja, es gab ja zwei. Ach übrigens, wollt ihr mal raten?
199.
So, also die SPD, eine Volkspartei, hat zwei mit damit gewissen. Und naja, gut, schön. Kommen wir jetzt, bevor die Sendung vorbei ist, zu dem Wahlprogramm und dem Wahlkompass digital. Es entstanden am Humboldt Institut für Intelligenz und Gesellschaft. Und wir haben schon geklärt, ihr habt euch die Parteien angeguckt, die laut der Umfrage 2016 mal über fünf Prozent gekommen wären. Ist also auch die AfD dabei, ist auch die FDP dabei und die, die jetzt im Bundestag sind. Was für Themen habt ihr euch denn angeschaut?
Wir haben versucht, eben alle möglichen Digitalthemen zu identifizieren, also in allen Bereichen Arbeit, Wirtschaft, Soziales, Sicherheit, Datenschutz. Es muss eben einen Digitalbezug haben. Das war für uns besonders wichtig, weil wir gemerkt haben, dass Digitalpolitik mittlerweile sozusagen in allen Bereichen eine Rolle spielt. Und wir wollten einfach einen Überblick geben über die verschiedenen Themen, sodass wir das gelabelt haben. Und wer sich für ein bestimmtes Thema interessiert, kann dieses Label klicken und dann sehen, wo das überall auftaucht in verschiedenen Programmen. Und er kann diese Programme auch vergleichen.
Jetzt haben wir schon im Rückblick festgestellt, also so richtig doll viele Unterschiede zwischen den Parteien gibt es meistens nicht, wenn es Digitalen gibt. Wie ist das denn jetzt im Wahlkampf? Da will man sich ja möglichst absetzen von den anderen und sagen, hier wir sind die Allerschufsten. Wird das im Digitalbereich auch gemacht oder ist das noch so, wir sind zwar im Neuland drin, aber das Digitale ist eher so hinten dran?
Ich glaube, dass es es gibt unterschiedliche Akzente. Alle Parteien haben das haben das doch schon sehr stark verankert. Allerdings würde ich sagen, in der unterschiedlichen Tiefe und manchmal, also gerade wenn es an institutionelle Fragen geht, dann gibt es doch deutliche Unterschiede. Wie das Digitale überhaupt verankert werden soll in der Regierung, wo die FDP zum Beispiel ein Digitalministerium fordert, dem haben sich jetzt alle kleinen Parteien in Teilen jedenfalls angeschlossen, oder ob es Digitalrat geben soll, wie das die CDU vorschlägt. Ganz interessant auch die Diskussion, die auch schon länger läuft, wie die Rolle des BSI aussehen soll. Also ob das immer noch das Bundesamt für die Sicherheit der Informationstechnik, ob das immer noch sozusagen eine nachgeordnete Behörde des Bundesinnenministeriums bleiben soll oder eben unabhängiger Garant für IT-Sicherheit.
Und das wäre, also um das sozusagen aufzuzeigen, warum das ein Unterschied ist, das Bundesinnenministerium sind ja auch die, die im Zweifel zu sagen, Staatsrojanereinsatz und sowas machen. Und das BSI ist ja theoretisch die Institution, die dafür sorgen soll, dass unsere Systeme so sicher sind, dass nicht mal ein Staatsrojaner reinkommt. Kleiner Interessenkonflikt also.
Ganz genau. In München, das wäre auch eine Entwicklung, die man noch erwähnen könnte, ist ja CITES gegründet worden, auch im Rahmen des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes. Also eine Behörde, die Sicherheitslücken suchen soll, um die einzusetzen in der Strafverfolgung.
Wer hat uns denn das eigentlich eingebrockt? Die große Koalition, ohne Zweifel?
Ja, ohne Beteiligung des Parlaments. Also ganz geil, weil sie gesagt haben, wir brauchen... Ja, das ist total gut. Das kann man auch alles machen, ohne das Parlament zu fragen. Da hat man nämlich gar keine Abgeordneten Missgewissen mehr, weil man die einfach nicht mehr fragen muss. Da kann man nämlich einfach sagen, wir haben jetzt diese Cybersicherheitsstrategie und da gehen wir her und sagen, wir brauchen diese Behörde, um unsere Anstrengungen zu bündeln. Wir brauchen aber keine neue gesetzliche Grundlage, weil keine Behörde bekommt mehr Befugnis und das bleibt alles wie es ist. Wir machen das nur sinnvoller und effizienter. Wow.
Schön. Gibt es eigentlich, wenn man sich die Wahlprogramme anguckt, so eine Art Nordpartei? Also so Grundsätze sind ja irgendwie private Daten schützen, also die Gynallimine darf keiner rein, öffentliche Daten nützen, also irgendwie Transparenz etc. Überwachung abschaffen. So was gibt es sowas überhaupt? Kann man sowas wählen? Wenn ihr auf Chaos, auf wie heißt die URL? Streaming.ccc, nee, Media.streaming.ccc.de, wenn ihr da guckt, habt ihr gerade gesehen, wie sie so leicht fassungslos slash entgeisterte Blicke durchs Studio schweiften in der Hoffnung, dass es vielleicht so eine Partei geben könnte.
Es ist ein bisschen peinlich, das zu sagen. Aber wenn man sich das mal so anguckt, die Partei, die meiner Meinung nach ihre Forderungen am besten begründet, nicht die, mit der ich übereinschöme, ist die FDP. Zumindest in dem ganzen Digitalbereich, weil sie nicht nur sagen, wir wollen irgendwie so angemessene Informationsaustausch oder so ein Bullshit, sondern sie sagen, was du gerade gemacht hast. Sie sagen, was sie wollen und sie sagen, warum sie es wollen. Und sie sagen auch so nette Sachen, wir finden, es ist Quatsch, alle Bürger zu überwachen, weil wir uns das eh nicht leisten können. Deshalb sollten wir uns darum kümmern, nur die Einzelnen zu überwachen, die wir wirklich überwachen wollen.
Vor allem, man muss aber da wieder sagen, bei der FDP muss man wirklich diese Linie ziehen zwischen der Staat und die Bürger und Unternehmen und Bürger. Und sag ich mal, wenn es um Datenschutz im Bezug auf die Wirtschaft geht, habe ich da gar nicht so den starken Eindruck von Seiten der FDP. Da geht es eher wieder in den Bereich, wir wollen uns ja in Deutschland die Wirtschaft nicht kaputt machen und wir wollen ein bisschen mutig sein. Und es gibt da ein sehr interessantes Gespräch zwischen Christian Lindner und Frank Schirmacher. Ich glaube, das wurde mit gutem Willen angestoßen. Und man sieht, wie Herr Schirmacher dann immer weiter im Sitz versinkt und immer mehr so die Hand ins Gesicht rückt und einfach merkt, also Herr Lindner versteht nicht, worüber er spricht. Und das muss man eben da auch immer im Hinterkopf behalten. Mein Problem ist tatsächlich, jede Partei hat ihre Macken so. Es gibt einen Grund, warum ich damals in die Piraten eingetreten bin und nicht in eine Partei, die es einfach schon gibt. Und man muss auch sehen, dass die Parteien, wo man noch sagt, das ist am ehesten die reine Lehre im Wahlprogramm, da wird man aber auch teilweise so einen Realitätsabgleich machen müssen und sagen, wie realistisch ist es denn, dass man einen Kompromiss aushandelt, falls man denn Teil eines Regierungsbündnisses ist? Und sind Bürgerrechte wirklich der Bereich, wo wir uns in die Bresche schlagen? Und natürlich gibt es in allen Parteien Supernetzpolitiker, die sich dafür einsetzen, aber ob die sich insgesamt durchsetzen können, da habe ich überall meine Zweifel. Und das ist so mein großes Problem, was ich habe. Und ich kann jetzt tatsächlich noch nicht sagen, wie ich wählen werde. Und ich glaube, da geht es ganz vielen nur als genauso wie mir.
Ja, aber es ist auch ein bisschen fatal, seine Wahlentscheidung von netzpolitischen Themen abhängig zu machen.
Das ist gerade meine nächste Frage gewesen. Also wie hoch würdet ihr, jetzt kommen wir sozusagen nicht mehr objektiv, in Anführungszeichen, klar, aber wie hoch würdet ihr das persönlich sozusagen hängen? Also wie wichtig ist euch dieser digitale Block in einem kompletten Wahlprogramm? Wie hoch priorisiert ihr das? Oder kann man oder ich würde fast denken, man kann das eigentlich nicht mehr trennen. Also sagen, ich habe gerade sozusagen so eine Extremfrage. So viele theoretische Diskussionen wäre jetzt gewesen, okay, wir stellen uns mal vor, es gibt eine Partei, die macht alles exakt so wie ihr das wollt, nur im digitalen schlägt sie völlig in die Gegenrichtung. Würdet ihr so was wählen? Und dann dachte ich so, das kann man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so trennen, weil es so stark im Leben ist, das geht gar nicht mehr.
Ja, außerdem Job Security, man muss ja auch die nächsten vier Jahre nur was zu tun haben.
Ah, du möchtest also die Überwachungspartei wählen, damit Netzpolitik Org noch verstehe. Du sagst mir jetzt am Ende der Sendung, bekomme ich jetzt mit, dass ich eine große Verschwörung aufgesessen bin. Arbeitsbeschaffung für... Oh mein Gott. Aber weil Carla es jetzt schon gesagt hat, wisst ihr schon, was ihr wählt? Oder habt ihr eine Idee? Und das ist wie eine wie große Rolle hat der netzpolitische Teil gespielt? Christian?
Also ich hab eine Idee und eigentlich, wie du gesagt hast, das Netzpolitische hat eine große Rolle gespielt, aber im Kontext eben. Weil ich glaube, in vielen Bereichen Zukunft der Arbeit und auch das ist für mich auch ein interessanter Trend bei den Programmen. Digitalisierung heißt jetzt nicht mehr nur Internet, sondern ganz viel sozusagen auch Automatisierung in verschiedenen Bereichen. Und das scheint mir doch so wichtiges Thema zu sein, dass mich das schon wesentlich geprägt hat. Zusammen mit Privacy-Fragen, wo ich wirklich auch sozusagen allein in der Art und Weise, wie Parteien das verteidigen, einen Unterschied sehe. Und das ist für mich auf jeden Fall auch ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt.
Kannst du noch kurz umreißen, wie die einzelnen Parteien da stehen?
Wir haben es hier bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Also ich denke, es ist immer gut, das sozusagen an Beispielen zu klären. Und bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben wir es ja eigentlich schon diskutiert, nicht? Also jeder hat das irgendwo im Wahlprogramm. Aber an der Stelle mache ich sozusagen auch ein bisschen Werbung für unseren Wahlkompass Digitalis. Man kann eben auch ins Detail schauen. Man kann dann die Forderungen genau vergleichen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch wichtig, um eben, wie gesagt, auch die Kräfte in den Parteien zu stützen, die das auch unterstützen und die Abgeordneten auch daran zu erinnern. Nicht später dann. Denn ich glaube, es gibt auch in der Digitalpolitik und ich würde denken, auch unter Nerd sozusagen unterschiedliche Themen, die unterschiedlich wichtig sind.
Ich würde ja gerne sagen, jetzt noch ein populistisches Thema. So ein Fragen, wie da der Stand ist. Und das ist ich habe gerade überlegt, so womit das Ding ist, ist ja immer so eine negative Überwachung und Staatsruh. Das ist alles so fürchterlich. Und was könnte man denn noch im Wahlpokal schreiben, wo man sozusagen sagt, ja, das finden wir auf jeden Fall geil. Und das ist ja eigentlich Breitbandausbau. Also ich würde denken sozusagen, jede Partei verspricht uns jetzt mindestens Glasfaser bis an den Nachtisch.
Bis 2025.
Nein, bis nächstes Jahr natürlich.
Nee, bis 2025 steht da.
Im Wahlprogramm.
Ja, ich glaube, welches war das? Also Glasfaserausbau, wir sind quasi schon da.
Gut, also CDU bis 2025 gibt es, wer bietet mehr? Habt ihr da mal geguckt?
Niemand.
Was? Also niemand will hat einen konkreten, ich glaube, ich bin wirklich, ich glaube, es war die CDU. Niemand will so ein konkretes Ziel erreichen, hält und niemand erhält den Anspruch, kompletten Glasfaserausbau jeder Haushalt bis an die Haustür in einer bestimmten Zeitspanne zu haben.
Gibt es irgendwelche anderen Ideen, wie man breitbandiges Internet? Also ich meine, das ist ja auch so ein Thema, da könnte man ja total viel versprechen. Wir machen LTE flächendeckend für alle oder weiß der Geier was?
Vor allem ist es lustig.
Internet in Luftballons.
Ja, wenn man sich überlegt, alle versprechen einem Glasfaser, also durch die Bank weg.
Ja, das schon.
Und wenn man sich dann anguckt, was in den letzten Jahren passiert ist, wenn man sich denkt, wir machen jetzt so eine künstliche, lebensverlängernde Maßnahme für unsere Kopferleitung und momentan sieht es überhaupt nicht nach Glasfaserausbau aus, weil es halt irgendwie zu teuer ist, dann denkt man sich schon so, was ist bei euch eigentlich los? Also was denkt ihr denn, was dann nächstes Jahr passiert und plötzlich haben dann alle Glasfaser? Und ganz witzig sind auch so die Finanzierungsideen, die Leute haben. Ich glaube, die FDP will die Aktien, also will die Staatsaktien an der Telekom und an der deutschen Post verkaufen. Ich glaube, die Grünen wollen die an der Telekom alleine verkaufen und irgendjemand anderes will Mobilfunklizenzen verkaufen und damit das Geld für den Glasfaserausbau kriegen. Aber ich sag mal, selbst wenn man das Geld auf einen Schlag hätte, würde ich es ein bisschen für unrealistisch halten, bis 2025 überall Glasfaser zu haben.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle das Chaosradio 233 empfehlen. Da haben wir schon mal ausführlich über den Glasfaserausbau gesprochen. Und ich dachte sozusagen, wie wenigstens jetzt zum Wahlkampf verteilt jemand sozusagen, keine Ahnung, dicke Glasfaserbündel mit seinem Parteiaufkleber drauf oder so was.
Das ist kein schlechter Idee.
Richterentwürft Wahlprogramme. Was ist denn noch, was ich auch noch eine interessante Frage finde, ist, wir haben ja die Sendung angefangen mit dem Neuland Zitat von Merkel, die ja sozusagen quasi so getan hat, habt ihr mir erklärt, dass sie das Internet noch gar nicht kennt, was Quatsch ist. Jetzt, wenn man so in die Zukunft guckt und sich die Wahlprogramme anguckt, was ist denn die Technologie der nächsten vier Jahre, die völlig, also sagen, von der die Parteien dann völlig überrascht sein werden, dass sie jetzt ansteht und oh mein Gott, da haben wir ja gar nichts zu irgendwie auf dem Zettel?
Ja, also man stelle sich allein mal die Vorratsdatenspeicherung vor, wenn wir, wenn das sogenannte Internet auf Finks kommt und alle möglichen Gegenstände in meiner Wohnung plötzlich eine Datenspur hinterlassen. Und ich glaube, ja, also sag ich mal dieses real existierende Entwicklungen von immer mehr vernetzten Geräten und die vollkommene Unbereitschaft zu antizipieren, was so ein Überwachungsgesetz in so einer Umgebung dann ausrichtet. Also das zeigt mir mal wieder, dass man nicht genug sowohl Gewissen als auch Digitalkompetenz im Bundestag hat.
Okay, Internet auf Finks ist also ein Thema, was zumindest nicht in der ganzen Konsequenz bedacht wird. Was sind so mit autonomen Autos? Spielt das schon eine Rolle? Hat irgendjemand sich dafür eingesetzt zu sagen, yes, autonome Autos bis 2020 auf der Straße oder das Gegenteil, irgendwie verbieten, weil deutscher fahrspaß?
Ja, das hat sogar der Bundesverkehrsminister ins Spiel gebracht. Und da ist natürlich, ich mein, Autostandort Deutschland, da schreiben sich eigentlich viele, also die CDU und die SPD auch auf die Fahnen, auch die dahinter liegende Technologie, KI, soll gefördert werden. Ob man da allerdings genau versteht, was das für Konsequenzen haben kann, da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Vor allem auch bei Kontrollmechanismen, die SPD und die Grünen schlagen einen Algorithmen TÜV vor, lassen aber offen, was sie damit genau meinen und wie das umgesetzt werden soll.
Ja, es stellt sich dann ja auch eine ganz einfache Haftungsfrage, wenn mein autonomes Auto beispielsweise die Oma, die gerade irgendwie über die Straße huscht, anfährt, wer haftet dann eigentlich ich, weil ich in dem Auto sitze, der Hersteller des Autos oder aber der Hersteller der Software. Das sind dann halt beispielsweise schließlich der Kreis mit Softwarehaftung. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass man sich damit wirklich auseinandergesetzt hat. Und wie läuft dann so eine Versicherung beispielsweise ab? Und wie setzen sich die Prämien zusammen? Also sind aus meiner Sicht dann viele, viele ungelöste Fragen. Aber die wurden nicht nur in Deutschland noch nicht beantwortet.
Aber wäre ja trotzdem schön, wenn wir mal Vorreiter sein könnten und nicht irgendwie wie beim Breitbandaufbau.
Ja, aber ich glaube Autos ist da in Deutschland das ganz falsche Thema. Wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie weit man hierzulande beim Thema E-Mobilität ist. Also ganz traurig.
Ich habe heute gerade so einen schönen Tweet gesehen, wo jemand die Meldung kommentiert hat, dass VW gesagt hat, also wir können schon so einen Elektromotor bauen, aber dann bräuchten wir Geld von der Regierung, wie es so ein Riesenkonzern nicht schaffen kann, was Tesla alleine geschafft hat. Na gut, also was ich jetzt ein bisschen unbefriedigend finde, ist, dass ich, also ich will nicht sagen, ich bin nicht schlauer als vor der Sendung, weil das stimmt nicht. Ich weiß jetzt mehr, aber ich weiß nicht besser, wen ich sozusagen wählen könnte, woran ich das festmache. Habt ihr noch einen abschließenden Tipp an die Wählerinnen und Wähler da draußen, wie sie, wenn sie sich für Digitales interessieren, vorgehen sollen zur nächsten Bundestagswahl, die im September ansteht?
Ja, also ich würde mir wirklich Menschen raten, sich nicht nur die Bundestagswahlprogramme anzuschauen, sondern beispielsweise mal beim Netzpolitik nachzuschauen, was die einzelnen Parteien in der Vergangenheit gemacht haben. Denn wie wir schon gesagt haben, für Datenschutz sind alle und so weiter und so fort. Aber ich muss mich mal hier auch noch mal outen. Für mich ist tatsächlich Datenschutz und Netzpolitik mit ein ausschlaggebendes Thema dafür, ob ich eine Partei wähle oder nicht. Weil ich denke, es gibt viele wichtige kurzfristige Entscheidungen, die zu treffen sind. Ich glaube aber tatsächlich, dass die Frage, was mit unseren Daten geschieht, was für Geschäftsmodelle wir als legitime erachten in der Gesellschaft und so weiter und so fort, ganz viel auch zu sozialer Spaltung beitragen werden. Beispielsweise, wenn meine Krankenversicherung nach Gesundheitsdaten mir einen angepassten Zahnputzwenigputzertarif anbieten kann oder vielleicht jemanden mit Erbkrankheit dann anders behandelt. Also es hat alles, sag ich mal, Querschnittsmomente in allen möglichen Bereichen. Und der digitale Wandel wird auch aus meiner Sicht im Stichwort Digitalisierung, auch bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, großes Thema, immer mehr andere Politikbereiche erfassen. Und da erwarte ich, dass Parteien, die sich darauf bewerben, für die nächsten paar Jahre in einem Parlament sitzen und für mich abstimmen zu dürfen, wo er in meinem Namen indirekt da auch vorweisen kann, dass sie sich zumindest damit auseinandergesetzt haben. Und das kann man auch einfordern. Im Zweifel ruft man einfach seinen örtlichen Abgeordneten kurz vor der Wahl an und sagt so, ja, also Peter, jetzt ist die Zeit der Wahrheit wieder angebrochen. Ich habe mich das letzte Mal vor fünf Jahren gemeldet. Ja, wie sieht es denn aus? Was hast du denn so gemacht? Und wie stehst du denn zu folgenden Themen? Und selbst wenn dann eine Partei gewinnen sollte, wo eine Koalition drankommt, die wir uns alle nicht wünschen, sind da zumindest ein paar Leute, die ein paar ernste Gespräche geführt haben und vielleicht mal drüber nachdenken, in Zukunft einen Gewissen zu haben.
Okay, die Arbeit müssen wir doch noch selber machen. Christian, noch ganz kurz, wir sind fast wieder zu lang. Letzte Worte.
Versuchen, sich einzubringen, in die Diskussion zu kommen über gesellschaftliche Gruppen oder eben sozusagen in Parteien. Und ich glaube, da kriegt man am besten mit, was man auch gut findet. Und man muss den Dialog suchen, denn am 24.09. geht ja die Arbeit erst los, nicht? Und da darf man sozusagen nicht den Stimmzettel abgeben und die Stimme damit, sondern dann beginnt das Gespräch und das wäre mein Punkt.
Irgendwie endet es immer wieder da. Du musst doch selber arbeiten, Anna?
Ich würde diese ganze Wahlgeschichte nicht so fetischisieren. Also weil einfach, es ist eine Wahl, es ist irgendwie das, was an Parteien dann im Parlament sitzt. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass ich nichts anderes machen kann. Das heißt, wenn man irgendwie sagt, das ist irgendwie alles nicht so gut, kann ich ja trotzdem noch in meinem eigenen Wirkungsbereich Dinge tun. Zum Beispiel, dass jetzt diese ganzen Lobbypapiere für Gesetze verabschiedet wurden, liegt daran, dass genug Leute nachgenervt haben, bis sie halt gesagt haben, okay, es lohnt sich nicht mehr, das alles einzeln zu beantworten, wir machen das jetzt proaktiv. Und da würde ich einfach sagen, nicht unbedingt immer nur nach den Parteien gucken, sondern einfach mal gucken, was man selber machen kann.
Na schön, das war das Chaosradio mit einem Rückblick und Ausblick auf die Bundestagswahl. Und wir, also zu dem standardmäßigen Aufruf, geht wählen. Kommt jetzt also noch ein zweiter und der heißt, geht nerven. Vielen Dank Katharina, Christian und Anna. Und mein Name ist Marcs Richter, ich habe noch einen letzten Satz, und der heißt, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.